hi I'm Ian Johnson a software engineer
with Wolfram research and my talk is
about new and upcoming systems
functionality in the Wolfram language
I'll be talking about operating system
functionality like sockets as well as
Network packet capture and other
operating system programming so this
talk is going to be about systems
functionality in the Wolfram language
both some new stuff that's in 11.2 that
you can use as well as some future
functionality that we'll be adding in
later releases so the kind of the 11.2
stuff that you can play around with
right now I'm going to talk about is
memory available and some other like
system measurements that you can do with
that as well as some network programming
using the new sockets functionality that
that we have in in the Wolfram language
and then some of the future stuff that
I'll be talking about relates to cap
capturing network packets another kind
of network programming task that comes
up a lot as well as inspecting system
processes so processes running on your
system that weren't started or don't
really interact with Mathematica but you
can interact with those using some new
functionality as well as programmatic
control of some web browsers through
through web unit okay anyways okay so
the first function function we're going
to talk about memory available a new
function we added so that you can you
know there's there's always been memory
in use
which tells you how much memory is used
by the Wolfram kernel but that doesn't
necessarily represent how much memory
you have left in the system so you know
it's sometimes useful in computations to
know okay I have you know six gigabytes
of RAM left if I try and load something
that's larger than that you know I'll
fail or something else will happen so
memory available is introduced as a kind
of remedy for that so the basic function
that just returns in bytes kind of like
a
best guess of what you have available
there's lots more kind of fine-grained
statistics available under system
information that you can view so and a
lot of these are kind of like you know
pretty technical in terms of like what
the difference is between them and so
you know the the physical total that's
you know almost always accurate I don't
you know that that doesn't change but
the physical used in physical free
doesn't always add up so you know for
example this machine has 16 gigabytes
but then if I subtract the hoops I
subtract the total - they used that that
leaves 4 4 gigabytes left which should
be equal to free but it's usually not
yeah so there's usually a little bit of
you know gap between some of these
parameters with specifically with
respect to the physical used and free
usually its cache memory that was used
by a application that was closed and
it's still available if you restart that
application later on so yeah this is
kind of like a measure of you know how
much cache memory you have available but
yeah so so memory available can also be
accessed you know as a quantity through
system information and usually the you
know just because you know the time
difference between when you measure it
in one call and another call sometimes
it can be very small variations so
sometimes these aren't even exact you
know in between different different
calculations but yeah so so yeah that's
that's kind of useful you can make a
little dynamic window here that shows
you how much memory of the left and then
allocating a bunch of memory here well
you'll see it dip down a little bit and
then if I if I clear that
it jumps right back up so this is kind
of a little cool thing that you can now
implement in Mathematica kind of you
know inspecting that kind of memory
state okay so the next thing I'll talk
about is with Wolfram language so since
eleven point oh we've had client
capability of connecting to servers and
stuff using sockets that was socket
connect that we've always had
you know you can connect to Wolfram calm
or something we've always had that that
functionality to be able to connect to
another server however in 11.2 we added
an additional socket type we added the
zero and q socket type which I'll talk
about in a second and we also added the
ability to open like server-side sockets
so you know in socket programming that's
you know how you make a network
connection to any kind of machine or
sometimes to your same machine is you
open up socket connections and now you
can both connect to other services that
are running as well as run your own
services using sockets in the Wolfram
language by opening those connections up
and so the second the the same type that
we've always supported is TCP which is a
stream based protocol where it's you
know you just kind of get data as it as
it comes in there's not a clear
you know delimiter between messages
that's as opposed to the new socket type
that we we have 0 mq which is discrete
message base so what's really useful
about 0 mq is that you either get the
entire message or you get none of it and
so there's a lot of complication in you
know writing these web applications a
lot of times because you don't always
know if you have the full message right
so if you're you know reading or writing
a web page or you know typically reading
a response from from some web server you
don't always know that you've gotten you
know the full the full response yet so
you have to keep you know kind of
polling and waiting and you know go
through this parser State and it's very
complicated but when you have a message
based socket like that you either get
everything you need or you get none of
it so you don't have to worry about some
of that parsing state and the other
advantage of implementing 0 mq sockets
is that there's a lot of different
topologies supported so tcp is always
one to one you have your server and then
there's the client and they they have a
connection but with 0 mq you can start
to build out these kind of more you know
kind of graph network type type
topologies such as you know maybe
one-to-many where you have
one server and a bunch of clients
connecting to that Woonsocket endpoint
and kind of like a you know distributing
data like that
there's also pub/sub mechanisms where
you can have multiple clients connecting
to like different endpoints and have
when you write a message it can be
delivered to only some of the clients
and kind of control it like that so so
yeah you can have lots of different
topologies available with what's your up
queue
so we'll just so that now the the
function to open up a socket connection
to allow new connections so like the
server-side aspect of a socket is is
socket open so we just open open that up
and when you specify this automatic
parameter that tells the operating
system to just find any available open
port so in this case it found you know
sixty thousand nine hundred eighty eight
you can also specify you know if I know
there's a particular port I want to
listen on you can also specify that
sometimes it's useful to be able to look
up services so you can specify you know
like the HTTP service or something like
or FTP or something like that a lot of
times if you're not running Mathematica
with sufficient permissions you can't
open sockets on ports less than like a
thousand or something like that just due
to like operating system issues but yeah
so you can you can open socket
connections like that and then in the
Wolfram language you connect with just
socket connect but you can also there
are lots of other languages that have
zero MQ bindings that you can connect to
so you know we'll just connect to the
server there and so now we have both
sides of the connection and you can use
the read and write functions to to write
any kind of arbitrary expression on on
the on the socket connection so you know
here's a simple some simple expressions
writing writing out and when expressions
are sent using right they're received as
two 0 mq messages one is the full
expression and then there's a newline so
if I write this again
there's another new function that we
added which is called socket read
message which is to read a single
discrete message when you use read that
kind of expects to work with a stream so
it'll it has all this parser state and
they'll try and figure out you know okay
do I have the full expression yet do I
need to keep waiting for more data and
it handles all that for you but in some
instances you just want the kind of like
raw what was sent on on the stream is as
a byte array so you can use that with
socket read message so you know it's you
can see that the first message here is a
byte array is like 38 38 kilobytes
something like that and we now have lots
of you know I can do by doraid a string
of that that'll be some big input string
so yeah some big graphics object with
lots of lots of stuff inside it but yeah
so you can work with byte arrays that
way and there also other you know you
can use right string and binary right
etc if you're not writing expressions
you can kind of formulate whatever kind
of protocol you want on on that yeah so
that's 0 mq messages so TCP sockets are
usually when you have to connect to you
know web sites and stuff you're always
using TCP so you can open up if you the
default the default message for or the
default type of socket is TCP because
it's kind of the most common right now
and so when you open up a socket
connection typically in other
programming languages is you open up the
socket and then you sit in a loop
waiting for clients to connect and then
you have to accept the connection and so
it's kind of a little extra overhead
that you know you always just have to do
and so in the Wolfram language this is
handled automatically for you so when a
client goes to connect it is
automatically handled you don't have to
it's you know asynchronous in the
background you just open up the socket
and now anything can connect
automatically so so yeah so now and in
you access for this is different than 0
mq with TCP because it's one-to-one
every single client that connects to
your your new socket that you just
opened is an individual different socket
connection so you're like opening the
door so that new connections can be made
and so you access those like kind of
client so remote the other side of the
client connection through this property
called connected clients so I'll just
connect one and and there you go
there you can see there are two two
clients I evaluated it twice so there's
there's the two clients so now to
communicate with that particular client
you can now do you know individual
client based communications is you just
do a write write or write string
whatever and then because on TCP it's a
stream based protocol when you socket
read message specifically it's kind of
undefined how big the the array that you
get back is a byte array you get back is
so here when I run this
I think I need to do the other one
because now there's two clients
yeah there we go
I always thought this we do this
but oh yeah so you can see that you know
when you're using TCP sockets it's it's
hard to you know guarantee how big of a
message that you get back on it so yeah
so that's like kind of synchronous you
know view control both ends with with
Mathematica also another really useful
thing that you can do is you can do
asynchronous listening and asynchronous
actions such as with with socket listen
so you know using handler functions here
we just have a simple one we're just
print something again this automatic
parameter says just find any open port
so we'll just connect to that sock to
the socket that was open for us and
write a message and then if I open up
the messages window we can see see that
message
you know so so there's there's our
message that we sent hello world you
know the time that kind of thing okay so
yeah so you can that that's a simple
example where you're just printing off
the requests that you get however you
can do a much more complicated one
that's not too much more complicated
it's just complicated in what you're
sending back is you can generate some
HTML code and send it back as a response
and now now you're implementing a web
server in Mathematica so I'll just build
up the URL if I open that in my browser
window you know there's there's our
little web server that's running
natively in in the Wolfram language so
that's fully asynchronous so that's
pretty cool there so yeah so and then
with that you know there's another kind
of like bonus feature if if you want is
you can use a socket listen in
conjunction with local submit because
what local submit does is it starts a
new it's another new and 11.2 function
and it starts kind of a sub session that
is independent from the main kernel that
you can still interact with it and get
you know data from that local sub
session but now you're free to use the
the front-end and use your main kernel
without getting bogged down by
asynchronous requests because currently
the asynchronous requests that come in
are handled the same way that like
dynamics are updated so if there's a lot
of requests in your notebook that you
deployed it in you know that'll be
pretty pretty slowed down yeah so that's
all stuff that that's available to you
right now so I'm going to quick show
some some new stuff that we're working
on so this first function is called
network packet capture which it just
takes you know an argument of how long
to wait for and hopefully there's
something going on in the background
that we get yeah so so here's some you
know just a data set of what's going on
you know there's some encrypted this
destination port at 443 that's some sort
of HTTP thing going on in the background
but a useful thing that you often want
to do when you're gathering these
packets is be able to filter them so you
know I can say specifically
only give me packets that are being sent
to my machine from you know over HTTP so
you can specify what port you want and
then get something back with that so I
guess there's nothing going on in the
background during those 10 seconds but
there's also a there but kind of a very
rough prototype of a GUI similar to
audio capture where you can just start
capturing you know select which
interface you want and then after some
time you know it's a stop button and
there's there's your your data so you
can kind of do that interactive
gathering of packets and you can also
use you know filters to do the same
thing here anything there but yeah yeah
so so there's just some code here to
look at all the host names that are
accessed but more that's coming on on
this specifically is the ability to do
this asynchronously so if for you know
this will be useful if you're writing a
function in Mathematica and you want to
see what are the packets that are
accessed while this function is
evaluating right so what you can do is
you can use you'll be you'll have a
network packet recording submit which
does an asynchronous task and then you
can get the the result from the
evaluation result so and then will also
support importing why it doesn't scroll
all the way down there's a bullet down
there that you can't quite see yeah
there it is
so you'll be able to import pcap files
gathered from say you know Wireshark or
something like that and import them into
Mathematica as if you had gather them so
so that's some of the new stuff the next
thing I'm in a quick show is system
processes which is for interfacing with
processes in Mathematica so currently we
have you know run process start process
these kind of functions for starting
stuff from Mathematica but sometimes you
want to interface or you know control
processes that weren't started for
Mathematica or at least see if they're
running to see if there's services etc
so here I just run system processes and
now I get you know all these process
objects returned to me
you know some of them zoom in a little
bit here you know you can see Wolfram
Colonel is somewhere yeah so there's you
know there's Mathematica and you know
you can see the apparent PID and things
like that and you know search for
specifically just ones that match that
but then another useful thing that you
can do is you can actually kill these
processes assuming that you have
permission so here I'm just gonna open
up you know here's a here's a notepad
simple process and then I can kill kill
that process good exit full-screen but
you know you can you can kill processes
sometimes which is useful if there's
something you know I don't know that the
system started that you need to remove
and then also query properties you can
get out how much memory is in use by the
process as reported by the operating
system so that's slightly different than
you know memory available that kind of
thing you know how many threads are
running you can also see processes when
they're running they have like parent
PIDs if they're we're started you know
so like one process a starts process B
which starts process C you know kind of
a chain like that you can look at that
kind of stuff and you can actually like
build a graph of you know what's what's
all running on your your system so you
know you can see this this process over
here started a bunch of a bunch of child
processes which kind of went into that
so it's kind of just a little cool demo
thing then the last thing I'll show is a
package that we've we've developed that
we're going to put into the language and
kind of flesh out really well called a
that uses a protocol called web
webdriver and so it's a programmatic
control of web browser so I have a web
browser over here and from the Wolfram
language I can open a specific page and
you know click on things so here I
clicked on the navbar by evaluating this
click element and then I can type there
and go to that page and I can also
capture a screenshot of what what that
browser is doing that kind of thing so
yeah I think kind of went by some of the
new stuff fast
but I'll stop there and open up to
questions if there any questions yeah go
ahead
situation
sure
yeah
so so yes you could it'll be a little
bit of a hack because you have to be
careful not to kill the process that
you're running right but you know you
can get the process ID of the the
current running kernel and then you
could find all of the Wolfram kernels
that match you know that are called
Wolfram kernel DXE or whatever and then
remove your the one that matches your
process ID and then you could kill those
other ones I mean it's a hack you you
could run into some weird things with
that I so I I have not tried it no I
have killed the the process I was
running in before so
so yeah that's probably not desirable
but yeah there's lots of different
functionality you could do with that you
could you could at least be able to tell
you know hey are there other Wolfram
kernels running that would be something
useful to be able to say but you need a
running kernel to to run that so I
suppose yep
so with this no because this is just
looking at what the operating system
currently has there's another
functionality that coworker is
developing to remote SSH like evaluation
of things and so you know if you have
SSH access to that remote server you
could run SSH commands you know to kill
that process on a remote server from
from Mathematica so that functionality
would be available but it wouldn't be
directly through kill process
any other questions yeah go ahead so a
lot of this stuff is you know
development stuff so the new stuff
that's in here won't be in the notebook
but the first part that's in 11.2
that'll be unpassable a little bit later
today so you can look at the stuff
that's available right now to use
any other questions
okay cool I'll be in the basement by the
connected devices booth later on if you
have any more individual questions but
other than that thanks for your time
[Applause]